Cuál es el papel de Brasil en la
geopolítica global mientras Busca
acercarse más a China pero también
mantiene sólidos lazos con Estados
Unidos
entonces volver a acercarse a China pero
también en mantenerse cerca de las
relaciones comerciales con Estados
Unidos que también es una una un país
importante para los negocios brasileños
y y de esta manera pues poner América
Latina otra vez también en contacto con
con países de diversos diversos partes
del mundo precisamente china es el
principal socio comercial como ya lo
decíamos de Brasil pero representa
también este viaje una oportunidad para
que Beijing pueda reforzar su
posicionamiento en América Latina
Sí claro
a Medina hoy por hoy es el país que
representa el 27% de las de las
exportaciones de Brasil es decir tiene
un papel muy muy importante para los
negocios brasileños pero el viaje Más
allá de eso pues también trata de
acercar nuevamente Brasil a a China
porque en el último gobierno pues
tuvimos ahí un alejamiento entre los dos
países por decisiones políticas del de
la del presidente anterior entonces bajo
la el mando no de Lula Pues tratar de
ubicar Brasil y de esta manera también
llevar el América Latina a hablar no con
China de una manera más cercana aparte
de estos lazos comerciales o intereses
económicos que otros intereses puede
haber
Bueno pues como decía antes la parte
comercial es muy importante pero nos
alejamos de china en en el gobierno
anterior putimas ideológicos el tema de
la corona de la vacuna de china en
Brasil y los comentarios de anterior
Pues alejó el país un poco eh de de del
gigante asiático no y ahora pues intenta
llevar temas pero también llevar esta
intención de acercar eh Brasil de
acercar América Latina a a China y a
negociaciones con china
tienen en cuenta sobre todo la
importancia comercial que tiene China
para para la región para Brasil No para
de otro lado Lula también pretende
convencer a su homólogo chino gran
Aliado de Rusia Por cierto de formar un
grupo de Naciones para mediar en el
conflicto con Ucrania cuán relevante
será el rol de Brasil en este en este
tema
sí Lula ha hablado diversas veces que
hay que terminar este conflicto no y me
parece que si se empeña se empeña a
hacer el diálogo y a poner china en este
juego que es un país sumamente
importante para los negocios mundiales
puede ser que tenga éxito a a poner esta
estos gigantes todos en una misión de
negociación para poner un fin a la
guerra